this is really bittersweet you know this
is
the final daniel craig james bond film
the end of this 15-year james bond arc
with him is the character it's i love
talking about it but it is kind of sad
so let's talk about it
[Music]
so no time to die is the newest james
bond film as daniel craig as the titular
character also his final run as james
bond and it's been a wait for this movie
how long await that was me in the
spectre review
here i am now it's been a while he's in
retirement but he comes back as james
bond as characters like this do because
they can never stay retired for long
spots one of those guys where how many
times has he been like i'm out of the
game they just like i'm back in the game
anyhow romney malek is the villain in
this movie as his nefarious james bond
villain-esque plan that he's gonna do
it's all world scale and definitely
feels world scale and now here we are
the final daniel craig run is james bond
and he's still crushing it as james bond
i've always loved daniel craig as james
bond because how's it started out it was
in this era where christopher nolan did
batman begins it was a more grounded
take on batman and then casino royale
came out it was like daniel craig is
james bond but a more grounded take on
james bond craziest tech he had was a
defibrillator you know it's like very
realistic take granted they've leaned
into the crazy tech as the movies have
gone on and i can't speak for everyone
else but at least in this movie i was
kind of like yeah yeah emp watch why not
i don't know i'm leaning into it at this
point but it seems like he's leaning
into it as well you know
there are more james bond one-liners and
puns in this movie than i've ever seen
daniel craig james bond throw out there
nothing quite as colorful as i thought
christmas comes only once a year but you
know the puns are here and the action in
this movie is gorgeous it's beautiful i
was just amazed watching it i'm like oh
hey it's a car chase sequence and it's
not cutting away from the car
every second and a half it's easy to
view the action the action is intense
the close calls you feel those close
calls you're like whoa that car almost
hit i'm not even there i don't know why
i felt like it almost hit me but it did
that's what you want from a movie like
this you want to feel like you're part
of the experience you're part of the
action you want it to feel dangerous you
know bond should feel dangerous also
felt for the most part there was a
synergy among the characters that worked
out for a very entertaining bond
experience standouts this time around
though it's not the first time they've
been standouts our cue in many penny
them working together as the two friends
that james bond really does have in this
world i just i've loved them before in
that respect i love them now in that
respect they don't admit how close they
are they feel more like family and i
love that also lashana lynch yes she's
the first female 007 which is all we
heard about her character because that's
the important thing on social media
gotta get that traction but in a world
where this movie had a lot that worked
with it for the universe and the
character of james bond i felt she was
another element that worked she's more
the soldier i mean all double-o's are
essentially soldiers but she's more like
no king in country less play you know
she's less james bondish but in a world
where james bond is retired and they
have nine numbers to work with because
double o o doesn't make any sense
neither does double o ten you can't hang
up these numbers like they're basketball
jerseys or something you know you're
gonna have another double o agent take
over some of the internet might have the
idea that she just like nudges james
bond out of the way it's like it's my
movie now she never comes across that
way she is a support character in a
james bond movie doing what support
characters in james bond movies do which
is back up james bond in his movie
granted like you don't feel like the two
like each other but i suppose they're
not supposed to like each other he was
double 07. she is double 07. they're
both threatened by each other in their
own way but it's not like it's ever
one-sided they're both threatened that's
key yeah she jabs at james bond james
bond jabs back at her that's just dick
measuring that's how it goes but because
first female double 07 kind of hijacked
the conversation i didn't hear much of
anything about anader amaz in this movie
and i loved her in this movie i actually
wanted to see more of her which i guess
that's the secret leave the audience
wanting more but she comes across as
more the bond vibe you might be
expecting she has her sexy silk dress
and she's a spy so she's kicking ass as
a spy in her sexy silk dress granted for
one scene that she's in i mean her
fighting in a silk dress is like james
bond fighting in a suit it doesn't make
sense but it's that it's that cool sleek
nature that we expect from a bond movie
but between her fulfilling that lashonna
lynch being more the soldiers like she's
in tack gear for most of the movie you
have yourself contrast among the female
dynamic in this movie and i thought the
contrast worked really well all the
while keeping the focus on daniel craig
as james bond and this being his final
farewell as the character now rami malek
as the villain in this movie i mean the
villain has this world scale scheme and
you do feel like dude we have to stop
this or the world's just forever
and i like the fact like you should feel
like that romney malek's character in
this movie i wouldn't put him up there
with mads mikkelsen's character from
casino royale or javier bardem in
skyfall he has a couple of good dialogue
scenes romney malek was good as the
character i just don't think the
character had enough to do this scheme
the weapon they're trying to stop stands
out more than the villain who's trying
to enact it in the end i had a really
good time in this movie it's the longest
james bond movie ever
sometimes it feels long but i didn't get
up to take a pee break and i asked for a
diet coke and dude the things like this
i didn't know what i was getting into
it's been a long time since i had any
concessions those theater beverages
wow no one needs to drink that much
liquid in one sitting but i had to pee
but i didn't take a break so there is
that you know i feel like that's a good
metric it's like is the movie
entertaining for the run time it's
always been an interesting arc that
they've been doing with james bond in
this bubble this five movie bubble james
bond before daniel craig was always you
know you want the james bond tech you
want the gear you want the cool spy job
you want to get the girl but these bond
movies have always been yeah you want
that life but do you want that life you
know because that character might have a
lot of pain that comes with that world
he showed us the human being behind the
myth of james bond he's still got it he
still maintains that james bond essence
but also shows character growth over the
course of the past 15 years and five
movies which is where we start getting
into like the pr for this movie has been
it's been terrible but they knew
that either because all press is good
press let's start an internet bus fire
fight it's a bond for a post me too
world well it's an interesting way of
saying james bond has an arc and he's
grown over the years also he's found
love and as we saw in casino royale if
he finds love he will give up his job
for that love it's an extension of that
we're dealing with the same character we
dealt with 15 years ago just an older
more seasoned version of him but hey
that's not trendy that won't get the
likes and retweets gotta say it's a bond
for a post me two world that'll get the
retweet right but that's still a
simplified way of describing the
character arc the 15 year five movie
character arc most characters and actors
should hope for such a grand farewell
and a grand farewell it was this is a
movie that's worth watching and worth
buying on blu ray alright so no time to
die have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's the order of the
daniel craig james bond films from best
to worst what do you love what don't you
love whatever there are whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you